das hier ist das haus in dem text so und
ich wohnen
wir kochen nicht wir räumen nicht auf
wenn der müll überhandnimmt sind wir
einfach dazu so interessiert nichts
anderes als die bäder
er trinkt nicht raucht nicht mit ochs
als die tochter von schock sein hoxhaj
wiederum ist so was wie der japanische
albrecht döderlein ist natürlich
völliger schwachsinn aber es ist eine
der größten japanischen künstler die je
gelebt haben er hat gelebt im 18 und 19
jahrhundert und von ihnen sind diese
kreuze wellen die jeder kennt wenn man
an japan denkt also diese großen wellen
mit diesen milchschaum obendrauf
er malt einen riesigen body dame auf
einen bogen papier der die größe von 120
tatami matten hat und dann wiederum malt
er zwei spatzen auf ein winziges
reiskorn es wird eine geschichte
sozusagen in episoden erzählt das heißt
man kriegt verschiedene einblicke in das
leben des meisters und zwar auf dem
umweg also über die bande über die
tochter gespielt dieser schrulligen
weniger tief ist mein vater so lange wie
ihr vater und tochter zwei pinsel und
vier essstäbchen haben bringen wir uns
immer
die schöne an dem film ist dass da drin
im grunde bilder andere bilder angucken
das heißt es ist eine art verschachtelte
seele es seine art einführung ins gucken
drachen sind nun mal anders als andere
wesen
darum muss man sie anders zeichnen
dadurch dass die vorlage ein manga ist
ein japanischer comic der von der
tochter eines künstlers handelt die
wiederum selber künstlerin ist und der
film macht es so dass er die sachen
ineinander ein schachtel das heißt man
kriegt teilweise im zitat tatsächlich
alte kunst zu sehen manchmal bewegt sie
sich manchmal bewegt sie sich nicht
manchmal bewegt sich auch der trickfilm
nicht und man hat so eine art fächer von
visuellen techniken von bisschen
computeranimationen bis hin zu sehr
sorgfältig gemalter klassischer folien
animation
das interessante ist dass japanische
animation eigentlich immer schon
schwächen der technik zu stärken gemacht
hat also dass beispielsweise die art wie
das ruckartig ist als erzähl mittel
benutzt werden kann und die art wie
dieses sozusagen judo artige aus der
schwäche eine stärke machen den ganzen
film durchzieht ist eine wunderbare
fließende bewegung von anfangs kenne ich
habe uns ein bento gekauft vielen dank
also man kann auch mit kindern reingehen
es soll gar nicht verbunden sein aber es
ist kein kinderfilm
nun sind kinder ja leute die auch
manchmal die schnauze voll haben davon
dass immer alles für kinder also schoko
zigaretten für kinder sie wollen viel
lieber mal richtige probieren soweit
insofern kann man auch mit kindern
reingehen ich habe gehört das hat er
nicht mehr viele aufträge hat aber in
der tat ist es so ist sollte sich
langsam herumgesprochen haben dass
gerade japanische zeichentrickfilm
genauso wie japanische comic also manga
nicht exklusiv kindliche themen kindlich
sichtweise weiter behandelt und bedient
hier ist es einfach so dass erwachsene
daran ist dass das ding sich zeit lässt
das ist psychologisch sehr fein
gearbeitet ist und ich kann mir
vorstellen ein kind das einfach
durchgeschüttelt werden will im kino
setzte ich furchtbar langweilen das soll
dann in die minions gehen wie auch toll
sind übrigens
deine letzten bilder von schönen frauen
sind hervorragend gelungen daran reiche
ich einfach nicht heran was nein sicher
nicht